- We'll probably be making a decision
in January or February, we're
going to see what happens.
The polls have come out, they've been
unbelievable strong, they say I'd win.
- [McKay Coppins] The
interesting thing about Trump
is that he's been threatening
to run for President
for basically 25 years, all
the way back to the 80s,
when he gave a speech
in New Hampshire and saw
a bunch of newspapers all
over the country write stories
wondering or speculating
about whether he would run.
This is the first time
he's actually filed papers
and is out on the campaign trail.
And I think a lot of people
are surprised by that.
(suspenseful music)
- There are a lot of
reasons for Donald Trump's
popularity right now in
the Republican Party.
One of them, I think, boils
down to the celebrity effect.
If you look at the polls, he does best
with voters who are not as likely to vote
in Republican primaries.
So imagine a pollster calling you up,
and reading you a list of
17 different candidates
and then asking who you support:
chances are, Donald Trump may be
the only person you've heard of.
- I'm not using the lobbyists, I'm
not using donors, I don't care.
I'm really rich, I'll
show you that next time.
- Trump appeals to people's ideal of
what they would do if they were rich.
They would have fancy suits and
big, private airplanes, and
hang out with supermodels.
Trump's entire persona
is sort of geared toward
the dreams and fantasies
of what wealth is like
for the average blue-collar,
middle-class worker.
- I guess I cause controversy,
and for no reason.
- A lot of people don't like
the political-correctness rules
that govern how we talk,
and what we can say
and Donald Trump flies in the
face of all of those rules.
All the way back to his
announcement speech,
when he made a lot of really
crazy comments about Mexican immigrants.
Or when he attacked John
McCain's war service.
Or when he got into a feud
with Megyn Kelly at Fox News
and suggested that during the
debate she was menstruating.
He is the billionaire who
doesn't play by your rules
and isn't governed by
political-correctness.
And that's what a lot of
people like about him.
- Mexico is sending people
that Mexico doesn't want.
And everybody knows
that's what I was saying.
- One reason Trump gets away with saying
such outrageous, ludicrous
things all the time
is because Donald Trump has a policy
where he never apologizes for anything.
And by virtue of never apologizing,
it makes it so that
people just assume that
it just wasn't that big of a deal.
- I'm a Republican, I'm a conservative,
I'm running, I'm in first-place
by a lot, it seems,
according to the polls.
- [Coppins] Can he win
the nomination? Sure!
(laughs)
He could win the nomination,
I think most people would
still say it's unlikely.
If you think back to fall of 2011,
Rick Perry was leading in
the polls at that time.
Of course he didn't become the nominee.
Fall of 2007, Rudy Giuliani
was leading in the polls.
A lot of people that lead in the polls
at this point in the campaign,
don't actually end up
becoming the nominee.
(musical tone)